Well,
I would like to get started.
Good morning.
Yeah.
Uh,
I had the discussion section.
I realized I sort of screwed my last lecture,
didn't come pride clearly through,
uh,
either here or Marx theory of alienation.
So I would like to come back to,
uh,
the theory of alienation and how Mark's gets to,
um,
the,
uh,
bat his manuscripts,
before we get into historical materialism.
And,
uh,
let me just,
make,
uh,
two introductory comments about this.
Uh,
one important point I tried to make is,
uh,
um,
you have to be,
I think one purpose off my lectures in Mark's is to alert you that there were
two marks is not just one,
and you are likely to know only about one marks,
right?
This is Mark's who had the theory of class struggle and the theory of
exploitation,
right?
And who was a theorist of,
uh,
communism,
but you may know very little about marks.
The idealists that he'd Galley and the humanist,
uh,
um,
who was central idea was the notion of alienation,
right?
Um,
who's major concern was about the human conditions under modernity.
And wonder to overcome it.
And uh,
you know,
these two very different and Marxists appear to very different audiences.
And in fact,
the first march,
the humanist,
uh,
did he galleon the idealist was almost forgotten for a very long time and was
rediscovered by the 1960s onwards generally.
And so it's very important to see that most likely that what you heard about
marks and I suppose most of you have never read any text from Max as a biased
view.
You only move one marks and not bulls.
And my point is to try to introduce you to the complexity that you meet boss
Carl Marx.
Right?
The second point is at that was what I found a um,
a frustrating then the discussion section yesterday,
which was one of diverse I did in the last couple of years,
not ever in my life.
I did even for us discussion sections.
But this was the real bad that,
you know,
the importance and the significance of Marcy theory of alienation did not come
through.
And I obviously did a very bad job because there are very few text written in
the 17th 18th and 19th centuries,
which are so powerful as so influential and so broadly influential on theories
of the 20th century that exactly this text on that Ian Asia.
Ah,
you can sync about literature,
right?
And you can see the extra ordinary impact of the idea of alienation and
literature.
Some of you may have read are their commune,
the French novelist,
the stranger.
This is right out of the theory of area nation.
You may be familiar with Franz Kafka,
right?
There you go.
That's the sense of alienation.
You may have watched ever the play wonderful play of Henrik Ibsen bear good.
That's about alienation,
right?
So in the 20th century literature,
the are full with the senses of alienation.
And so his 20th century social theory,
that is no 20th century social theory.
[inaudible] theory of alienation by the way,
is interesting because of that,
his manuscript for the first time was published only in 1930 wrong,
never the less,
the idea was already beginning to creep in earlier.
Smart people read that theory of alienation in Mark's earlier girl Glucophage
for instance.
And then the friend first school,
there is no door,
no,
there is no work time or there is no mark Koser.
We saw the theory of area nation and I can go even further.
There is no cultural theory.
We saw the theory of alienation.
There is no Bauman,
there is no color Kowski beside the theory of alienation.
This is a very important idea.
So I have to come back to this and to try to show you how he arrives at this
point.
And Vi he abandons it by the second Marxism merging and then he get it starting
with the second marks,
the first step Dover's the second marks is the thesis on fire.
But I want to talk about her today and I tried to economize with my time.
Right?
Um,
all right.
I have learned from Adam Smith's right to be more utilitarian and to make sure
I,
that needs some ants do match with each other or k,
let's come back to Hagar and he goes,
theory of alienation because I don't think from the discussion section,
my sense was I did not make it clear enough,
but he goes to your ears and,
uh,
well,
um,
let me,
uh,
try to labor on this.
Um,
uh,
as I said,
you know,
he was an idea this,
and I hope I explained it to the extent it is necessary.
Have you come back to this then I'll be,
I'll be talking about the thesis on fire back on the German ideology.
But he really thought that somehow,
um,
consciousness receipts,
a material existence,
and that's what made him into an idealist,
uh,
how religious he was.
I actually don't know.
This is not a religious,
not a theological propositions.
Now,
the idea is that before the physical word existed,
there has been an absolute spirit right at the origin of the world.
There is an absolute spirit existing and that existed.
The material Verdis such,
um,
uh,
and then,
his central idea is that you can describe the history of the universe as a
problem of Eliana nation as a problem of gradual separation.
As I said,
well,
I'm subject and object.
This is a very important idea and B,
you'll have to deal with this in marks.
And even,
um,
uh,
if you are dealing with 20th century theories,
critical theory,
this is a central notion of,
you know,
um,
subject and object.
Let me try to labor on this a minute and I have to do it on the blackboard.
So,
um,
uh,
he goes fundamental idea.
Yes.
That's when you have the absolute spirit.
Yeah.
All right.
Uh,
and this is not that person or God,
right?
But just the idea here,
this is a situation of totality.
The absolute spit it is at the same time subject and object United in itself.
Right?
And that's what he got costs totality.
And as the term totality being used,
the later on in critical theory and we are safe.
We are searching for totality.
We are searching for the unit,
young of subject and object.
Then he goes,
the second stage is that subject and object are divided from each other.
Uh,
that is the material world.
We,
south consciousness and consciousness becomes absolute consciousness because he
kind of projected the material word out of itself,
right?
And this is the,
this is the situation of alienation.
Uh,
object becomes separate,
okay.
Then as human being some of subject and the object beginning to merge,
right?
Consciousness emerges,
Okay.
Uh,
consciousness,
right?
These are subject,
this is you and the object,
the conditions of your life,
right?
And I'll dive bursts on you are interacting with is a sub object of your
interaction or the conditions of your life,
right?
Your objective conditions,
this room,
uh,
a year university,
the construction which is going out that rather these are objective conditions,
right?
And you are the subject who are reflecting on it,
but because you are gaining some consciousness,
right?
You are beginning to concrete the objective conditions of your life and what
he's suggesting,
right?
That alienation when overcome,
then your subject,
you'll be able to control the objective conditions of your life,
right?
When you're s value consciousness is Adec vet to your existence,
When you are the master of your life,
you are a master of your conditions.
It is not the conditions which rule you,
but you are the master of the conditions,
right?
That is the key idea,
uh,
in,
in Hagar and rice is very much following this idea.
I mean,
he of course,
eliminates the whole idea of absolute spirit,
right?
He doesn't want to,
uh,
deal with the idea of absolute spirit.
For him.
This is too speculative.
He's also bothered by the idea that you can overcome the problem of alienation
simply by thought.
Right?
Monks project is to bring this whole idea of alienation down to earth to
everyday experience.
To your experience and you experience of,
I've would use the term modernity until 1944 marks does not have a concept of
capital is more capitalist mode of production,
right?
Uh,
he even just vaguely thinks about private ownership is really tried to
conceptualize modernity,
more modern,
industrial,
urban life as distinct from earlier,
right?
Commune or life,
the life what we had in more intimate communities,
peasants of the villages or whatever,
right?
It tries to conceptualize this and he sees this is a progress.
Modernity has a progress,
but we have to have pay a heavy price for it.
And the price,
what with bay for these modernity is the separation of subject and object,
right?
The Besant in a village was not separated from the objective conditions of its
existence.
It was United with the objective conditions.
It was bound to the earth,
right?
Even the slaves were not separated from the objective conditions of that
existence.
They were treated as objects,
right?
There was no subject separated from the op shop.
So the unique as this is Mike's,
right?
This is not Hagle anymore.
And I the unique feature of alienation that you have the separation from subject
and object in modern conditions,
right?
And I think this is why Marx,
theory of alienation survived.
Mark Steer you of exploitation that the young Marx survived the older marks,
the first marks survived a second marks because we can all relate more if you
have a good lecture that and who brings more clue in more effectively to you,
but he's getting it.
You can relate more.
You can say much more.
I uh,
I feel alienated in this class,
right?
That makes no sense to me,
Uh,
this doesn't make any sense to my life and I have to see that because I'm a
sociology major and I have to take this bloody class,
right?
Then you are early and 80.
Right?
And this is when you follow your gut.
That's what you have.
You'll say,
right,
I am Ellie and ate it because I have to deal with this nonsense,
right?
Because they forced me to do so then you add alienated.
This is exactly what Marx is getting get right Manny,
that day it is your choice,
right?
You that a sociology major,
But then you are forced to do stuff that you don't really want to do.
So it doesn't mean right that you are not free.
You are free,
but we seen your freedom.
You are alienated because you don't control your conditions and it looks like
that.
We seen your freedom,
the sin,
you were free choice.
You are forced to do stuff,
right?
This is what Mark's trying to get at.
You think you are free,
you think you are equal with others and you are really not free because the
objective conditions but you create it for yourself,
right?
He will caught for trouble,
Uh,
who force you to be a sociology major,
lower body and then you are in the trouble that you have to do certain,
take certain hurdles but you feel alienated and you don't feel that your whole
personality is being developed.
Right?
To put it straight to John Stuart Mill,
you don't feel self development,
then you are alienated and Uri so,
right.
Is that a bit coming closer to it?
Makes more sense.
All right,
now let me therefore also show you how much gets through it.
I think this is very important and I skipped all of this stuff.
Um,
uh,
and because I was trying to get very quickly,
I was trying to get to quickly to the notion Marx theory of alienation.
Now I would like to correct this and I already foreshadowed in my last lecture
that these are fundamental double years for marks and 1844,
80,
43 and 1844 in two years.
His intellectual development is quite extra ordinary.
And let me follow you through of these intellectual development.
In the summer of 1843,
he writes this book a critical contributions to our critique of Hegel's
philosophy or fried or Vegas philosophy of law.
And um,
well he
has,
it has gone through a long,
um,
development,
uh,
intellectually he started out as a radical and admirer of the French revolution
and that's,
he was getting older.
He was becoming more and more conservative and was becoming concerned about the
consequences of the French revolution.
And,
uh,
and as he became cooler,
you know,
more conservative.
He was he so well what is happening with the French after the French revolution
is not really what I wanted because now the French revolution is actually
splitting the society in two classes.
Uh,
right.
capital and labor.
It's not exactly the terminology,
what he means,
but that's what he got is getting,
getting the philosophy of ride and who can tell who is right and who is wrong.
The,
our conflicts with each other.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the employers or the owners wants something and they're workers one,
sometimes something else,
they boss that present particularistic internist,
but they're easier universalistic intro.
So ask Kayla,
there must be some universal justice,
uh,
to put it in the terminology we use in this course before,
there must be something like common good,
right?
Which brings capital and labor together.
There are the,
or this common good come from.
And in the philosophy of ride,
he offers an interesting theory.
He said,
if you come from the government,
it's scarves from the state.
The state should represent the universal instance.
And then he said there,
you know,
the society,
modern bourgeois society,
which emerged as the result of the French revolution is these by I did into this
particular Isti classes,
but we need a universal agent,
right?
And Universal class,
which represents the common good.
And this must be the government,
right?
This must be the class of civil servants.
And in the book,
a philosophy of,
right,
which is his kind of last major book.
Uh,
I sit not long before he dies,
he argues these other civil servants who constitute the universal class.
Now,
this is not a silly idea.
We do think about this way.
And yes,
I mean,
he bills in many respects,
in a more sophisticated way on law can show and the idea of general via,
particularly in Rousseau,
right?
And this is the state which should represent the general there,
And we also occasionally think about this way,
right?
That are all these conflicts around this country.
And we expect the government right,
to express the universal interest,
right?
The innovator,
General Ville.
We expect occasionally the federal government to do that.
And the federal government,
occasionally it does.
It,
uh,
you'll have a read about the civil rights movement.
I mean,
who was the agency,
right?
Vich made sure that the states and surely obey the laws and integrates the
schools.
It was the federal government,
right?
It was Bobby Kennedy who went down and made sure that the southern states don't
follow the rules,
right?
The expected the government right to add have expressed the universal entered
us,
right?
So it's not silly,
but Mark's in know they said,
well that's not that simple.
Uh,
he ain't got his naive about the government and he says,
vow,
the government is not that non partial as we would like it to be.
All right,
if you are rich,
you have more influence on what the government does,
that you are poor,
right?
There are lobbyists in Washington DC,
right.
And you probably have her whole leverage on these.
Um,
uh,
lobbyists.
Big Business has a lot of leverage on these lobbyist,
right?
And they of course have a great deal of pressure on Vat.
The legislature will do just follow what is happening and that the house care
legislation,
uh,
well you can't call your congressman and you can send emails,
you know,
and can send letters and ask them to do something,
but they leave me.
Then the pharmaceutical industry spends a lot money and they also senator,
you know,
unless you vote this way or that way,
right?
We probably may not be able to support your next a lecturer campaign right now.
I need to be,
you make more impact than are individually email,
right?
Either you should not send individual emails,
send it.
Right.
Being walled my be over there,
right?
That the government is Sam to be more responsible for a big business.
So he said,
how can it be whenever,
as a class,
that's really the point.
But he's making in the philosophy of,
right,
right.
Let's say it is not universal.
If breed tends to be universal,
it has stupid,
tend to be universal in order to be legitimate,
but real.
It is not universal and the civil servants are,
of course not that universal class.
Okay.
On Day are quite corrupt.
Right?
Mack,
you'd do United States of course,
but in some countries I can think of see my serve and south court off.
Right.
You know,
and then they are offered,
you know,
a three seats,
and have private jets it,
they accept it and then they accepted it.
They do something for the owner of that private jet.
Right.
I,
so there are some civil servants who are not all of that in a sense.
Right.
And they can be influenced.
So it is not all that university of class.
They are,
not all CV was servers aren't angels.
Right.
Some of them are,
some of them are not.
In fact,
he concludes the Barn,
the finished book that really the problem is that if you don't have universal
suffrage rice,
he in 1843 and he said let's have universal suffrage and then if the in three
elections universally elect their representatives,
the problem VOB gone as we know.
He was not quite right.
Right.
We have old four vote.
But if you do not have or equal voice,
right.
I think that's a,
um,
but mice here is still a bourgeois libero as of the summer of 1843 believes the
problem will be solved.
Now let me rush through and show you the kind of intellectual development I'd
briefly pointed out to this.
These are the three important steps which follows a these abandoned manuscript.
He now enters the road of radicalization,
right move survey from Hager and tries to carve out his own intellectual and
political project.
And he writes the paper on the Jewish profession,
um,
in which he says,
well,
they,
he,
he got his right.
We need something universal.
These should not allow society just to be the struggle of particularistic
interest,
right?
It,
this is in a way against Adam Smith's and utilitarianism.
It's not enough that individuals fight each other interest out and that will end
up to a universal good.
Or we need some universal good to be achieved.
Now need to be,
have not simply achieved by particularistic interest followed that is,
uh,
Mark's point.
But then he writes a,
uh,
an introduction to the critique contributions to the critique of Hegel's
philosophy off right?
And then there's introduction.
He said the is something universal emancipation,
but Whoville bring universal emancipation to humankind.
Right?
He's looking for an agent who can carry this out.
And in the introduction he said this will be the proletariat.
Well you may say now he's entering their own growth.
Um,
and he's entering a very danger,
he basically painted himself in the corner of where he viewed before the rest of
his life trying to show that indeed the proletariat will emancipate us or,
and we'll create good society or such and bad people when they are reading the
introduction.
And I will give you a few citations from it because it's a beautiful piece of
work.
Um,
in many ways it is wonderful poetry.
He has some extra ordinary framing of the problem.
But then,
you know,
his critics said,
what a math sense.
You know,
why honors the proletariat as we all know,
the workers are dumb.
I mean are you are saying that the critical philosophers,
the cannot emancipate human kind,
but you think that these ordinary workers be alienated consciousness.
They the bring gas and on the Alia and I donated work.
How comes?
But the nonsenses this,
so that's when he rides a Paris manuscripts and try to now briefly the whole
idea of alienation down to earth to feel it to the sun economic content.
That's why now he crashed do related to commodity production and make the claim
that door.
In modern society everybody is alienated but they are only the earth who are
fully [inaudible] and that interest is to overcome the Eliana nature.
That's what this is why he tries to,
I view that alienation.
We are bringing the working class to emancipate humankind.
That is the project.
Of course,
he'd never publishes the book because after he wrote it down he said,
oh I suppose he said,
well this is quite nicely written.
I have a couple of good ideas but know about the deal.
Believe me right now working class will not go on the battery case and die
because I am telling them that they are alienated,
right?
They don't care about that IA nation.
I have to come up some,
some better lesion,
you know,
by diverting birthing class of your rev ward.
And that's end of the young Marx.
And now he beginning to read Adam Smith and Ricardo and political economy,
right?
And he beginning to develop his theory of exploitation.
This is the young or mature marks and Vivi or talk about him very briefly now,
just a couple of ideas here.
All right.
Uh,
what about uh,
the own,
the Jewish question?
What is at stake?
I brought on Bauer,
wrote a paper on the origins of antisemitism and he said,
we have antisemitism in Germany.
Uh,
because the state is Christian and as long as the city is Christian,
if you discriminate against the Jews to the solution is to separate the state
and the church to have political emancipation,
right?
And if we have political emancipation,
the abolish antisemitism.
Now Mark's stakes is born here.
And he said,
look,
this guy is completely wrong.
Look at the United States.
The church and the state are separated.
And the 19th century,
there was quite a bit of antisemitism in the United States,
not only in the 19th century,
in this very institution in the 1920s and thirties,
there was a lot of anti Semitism cause I'd wonder if we'll,
uh,
sociologists,
Jeremy Karabal wrote a great book about the admission policies of Ivy League
universities and the 1920s,
and he was able to prove that in the Ivy League universities,
including Yale,
actually applied their quota.
They never edited more Jews to Yale,
then the every Jewish population in the United States.
Believe it or not,
it was never official policy,
but it was practice all the time.
Um,
so I mean,
there was antisemitism.
Antisemitism can exist if the state and church are separated.
If the state is supposed to be secular.
And Mark said,
there does come like racism.
Uh,
come from you said it comes from what he said,
civil society.
He doesn't have the notion of capitalism.
He said,
this is rooted in people's everyday experience and interest,
right?
Antisemitism comes from civil society because some people feel threatened by the
Jews.
Why is that?
You know,
Auntie African American feelings because some people feel threatened by
everything.
I'm Americans.
Right?
And this is why that dad is racism.
So you have to fix the problems in civil society.
The problem is in civil society,
not in the state.
Therefore what you need is universal emancipation.
That's the bottom line on the Jewish Russian.
Is that reasonably clear?
Okay.
That last go for it further.
And this is the introduction,
uh,
well,
that are some wonderful stuff in this,
uh,
it's more poor three then it,
it is certainly not social science.
I would say more poetry,
but very forcefully don bell.
He said,
uh,
what we have to do is to move beyond Feuerbach Oh,
who simply sort of contemplated on the situations and he said once the holy form
of human south estrangement has been unmasked,
that's what Feuerbach did,
right?
He did show that Addie,
yeah,
nation is our leave projecting out alienation by creating God ride.
He said,
now the task is too on the mosque,
self estrangement or alienation and it's on the holy form,
right?
In a,
in the everyday life,
in your everyday experience,
especially in you would economic activities.
That is the point,
what he tries to make.
Then he goes further and he says,
well,
the young key galleon shad be critical.
Critique,
criticize,
or he galleon teary and I seen,
this is a fantastic sentence,
I guess.
Beautiful poetry,
uh,
very dangerous and let a lot of trouble in history in a way.
I wish he would not have written it down,
but I love that he did write it down because it's a beautiful sentence.
The veteran of criticism cannot replace the criticism by veteran right now.
It's not enough to be critical in thought.
You have to be critical in action,
right?
You have to act on it just below.
Just stock.
Do something about it.
That's what it says.
Well,
I think this is,
you know,
one of the strongest sentences I have read in social science literature,
right?
The veteran of criticism cannot replace the criticism by veteran.
Now this is also a great sentence.
Do you becomes a material force as soon as it has grasped the massive grip to
the masses.
Dod Is Capable of gripping the masses.
As soon as he demonstrates ad Hominem.
Whoa.
That's why something,
uh,
about he arrived.
He said,
well,
the question is what is a good theory?
Watch real.
How are you,
you,
you emancipate yourself.
Good.
The essence of good theory that it grabs you at grips.
You right?
When you say,
Aha,
it did it me,
this is theory,
right?
But it can only be,
then it is ad Hominem when it is addresses your problems,
right?
Acuity what you are lost.
You don't know why it is relevant for you.
Life is no good.
I would even go as far the Curie,
which is boring is bad theory,
but you need is fascinating theory.
You have to be fascinated.
You have to be fraud,
right?
You have to be say,
yes,
no,
I will live differently after I the I this theory,
I understood,
right?
It has to move you.
That's the good theory.
I think that's a,
that's a wonderful point,
right?
And very powerful.
The down.
And then he said,
well,
Martin Fowler,
and he see that the theory has to grab the mask is not what kind of Mashes,
who is our audience?
Well,
and he says,
be in order to carry out a revolutionary change,
it's not enough to have a theory,
not enough to have ideas.
Uh,
you mean need?
He said that's a very problematic but very crucial to understand the downside,
the side of Marxism,
passive ally man's right and material base,
right.
As you see,
no matter how much,
uh,
Mark's,
glorifies the Verking class or thinks about them as a passive ELA math,
right.
A simply as a material days.
And that is who is that?
The proletariat and why?
Because it has muffing clues,
but he changed.
It has a universal character and this is why it is the universe,
our class,
uh,
and you know,
and 1843,
it may have been quite cracked.
They're working class poverty has little else to lose,
but he changed certainly in 2009 is usually not true.
The Virgin class has much more to lose any change.
Right.
It has probably its own nice suburban.
They probably own two cars.
They probably even have some Benjamin fung ride on the stock exchange even or
definitive workers checkout what the Dow Jones did yesterday because it affects
that impact.
But in his times it was probably true.
So this is how he gets to the problem.
It is the proletariat.
Every trivial would be the universal class.
And now you are already familiar with the Paris manuscript and ivy are not
talking about this.
That's why he wants to show that the proletariat is the most alienated and that
makes follows logically,
I think it damages to some extent the theory of alienation because it narrows it
too much down.
The focus is too much down on diverting class and innovate too much down on
working class,
working on industrial production in firms.
But really the message of alienation is much broader.
It Christ to Conaway you some general experience of modern life there.
The,
the do not feel at home.
This is the big framing of the problem.
Um,
and uh,
uh,
the Early 20th Century homelessness,
the homeless mind,
right?
That these feel homeless in this world searching for a home.
That's the sense of alienation.
That's what March tried to capture it here in a very own.
Fortunately,
ms specified,
too much emphasis on,
very curious,
just because he beginning to have this political project and wants to find that
evolutionary class.
Uh,
and you know,
he abandons it.
This is ridiculous.
You know,
we ha I have to put my show together and then he does a,
uh,
beginning to develop what he calls historic on that.
Cheerier.
I,
so let's get into that one and uh,
uh,
I have 10 minutes to do it.
Uh,
uh,
that's all right.
Uh,
if NASA,
Sheree Ivo come back to this,
so Mars is developing a,
he calls historical material is man,
the ivy will suggest it does make it,
it is done in two steps.
First a,
he's emphasizing dialectics in his criticism of fire.
Bang for your buck is a materialist store ride,
but he's a mechanic on materialist and Mark's wants to being dynamics,
uh,
in the,
his,
uh,
materialism.
And he will argue that this has to be at,
yeah,
historical.
He specified material force and this is what he will do.
Um,
in the,
uh,
the uh,
German ideology.
Um,
but what is dialectical,
I don't want to waste time on this.
I want to get straight into the thesis on Feuerbach,
which is a very short text but very GD.
Um,
uh,
so here are the 11 thesis of Feuerbach on Dcis on fire,
but he tries to carve out what his new,
um,
uh,
approach VOB.
Uh,
and these are the 11th thesis,
very sharp.
He said,
choir box material is my boss.
Simply reflective if actually manned subject and object remained separated and
the subject reflected on the object outside of the subject dominating the
actions of the subject.
But it is assume that there are objective conditions irrespective from the
subject.
And you only left left on the subjective conditions.
And he said they're all in the new material.
Is throughs is a practical question.
And I,
you're talking about this in a minute.
It means you have good breathe by human practice subject and object together.
You have to change your objective conditions of your life.
That's,
you know,
not a passive agent.
Not over Deta ammunition marks is overs red as a determinist.
No.
As I will say,
Mark's philosophy is a philosophy of praxis.
Praxis practical activity is the key of Marx theory men.
And then change his circumstances.
And how if you'll elaborate on this,
but you know,
we get shit.
You know,
we were born in certain conditions,
but we can change it right then.
Uh,
but in order to change the reality,
we have to become effective alone.
We have to cooperate.
There's seasons for he said that he was,
he thought that it can be done in thinking no.
Uh,
uh,
foyer backdoor to become Donny in contemplation.
Mark said no,
it can be only done by social practices.
Uh,
five,
six now or an attorney.
All his mum was looking at the individual.
Right now I will look at the collective social relations,
relational,
but I'm suggesting is relation.
Now they all,
religion is also a social product.
This is a kind of,
by the way,
social life is practical follows from what we have said.
Um,
uh,
how contemplation implies isolated individuals in society.
Um,
uh,
well the offer,
a view of socialized humanity,
that's the all act together and this collective action,
which means change.
And then the most controversial and most important one so far,
the philosophers and interpreted the,
now the point is to change it,
right?
Good theory is not just describes,
it gives you up to ascription what to do about your life.
That's the kind of theory what we want.
That's the thesis on fire Buck.
Just 11 sentences,
basic raid sentences,
salt of old materialism is,
uh,
reflective,
right?
The chief defect are Feuerbach is the dinks and he saw the German term is Gagan
[inaudible],
um,
uh,
ish reality.
Sensuousness feeling through our senses,
right,
is to go and see it only in the form of the object that he sends to the object
outside of our contemplation.
But censures asked is not perceived as human action activity.
Right?
We simply feel the staff,
what we don't do anything about that he says sensors activity is what I
emphasize.
There are new materialism.
This is,
you know,
one of the most important sentences.
Mark's throwed them.
Um,
there are the question that the objective choose can be attributed to human
thinking is not a question of theory,
but it is a practical question.
Mom mess must prove,
choose the,
this worldliness of his thinking in practice,
right?
It's not a speculative thing whether aggression if throughs.
Um,
the best of the pudding is in the eating.
He says as their,
um,
uh,
Italian Marxist philosopher on Donio grab sheet who died in the prison of
Mussolini called Marxism,
the philosophy of praxis.
That's the essence of Marxism.
That the trolls is not the subject reflecting on the object,
but the interaction of the subject between the object right there,
the subject changes the object in order to meet the need of the subject.
That's the major point.
The separation of subject and object.
The assumption that there are objective conditions which are outside of our
pastoral action is what later Marxists would call positive is,
ma'am,
Marxism is not positivist.
It believes that we can change the world that then just to accept of Erd.
Right.
Well,
I don't have to talk about,
don't have enough time to talk about the ground.
She just one word.
In fact,
he called Marxism as a philosophy of practice because he was writing his major
version in the prison of Mussolini and was smuggling this book out there called
the prison old books.
Um,
uh,
it was smuggled out before he died and he knew that,
you know,
the prison guards will read it,
so he did not want to ride down the term Marxism.
And then he met Mark Cisma.
He wrote it,
the philosophy of praxis.
And of course the stupid fascist,
uh,
guards did not know what honors philosophy of Praxis is.
So it did,
they did not know his writing get about Marxism.
But I think he got a very important point.
This is indeed an important feature of Marxism.
There a man changes circumstances.
Now,
circumstances can change by man.
And this is again,
a name potent Sam.
Then dance,
the educator must himself be educated.
And those are few in my discussion section yesterday,
this is what you did.
You educated the educator.
I realized I did not get,
you know,
the theory of area Neisha through quite effectively.
So I went back and collected my course,
right?
The educators must be educated,
I think that's a great sentence now and run these through.
Discover the role of the masses.
Now that's very much march political project coming in,
but any important project,
right?
That's you cannot do by yourself,
If you want to achieve something,
you have to cooperate.
You know,
you,
you need cooperation with orders,
right?
Um,
otherwise nothing can be achieved.
well,
uh,
he goes starting point was abstract thinking,
foyer blah.
He's a materialist.
He thinks,
but he's real is what we can grasp.
Vitaros census.
Maurice said,
no,
this is census.
Practical activity.
It has to be sensors,
but it has to be practical.
This is something,
but you're going Habermas laughter.
The German philosopher,
he said this is Jerry or marks who sees the essence of all tenses,
EC,
human activity being the court.
Later marks is that reduction is because he reduces sensors.
Activity to economic activity.
Here in Mark's perceives all sensors.
FDT including human interaction between us,
including sexual interaction among us as a,
as activity,
right?
As the material reality.
That is not so much a conflict between marsh and fried as it appears.
Now let me go for it
as six.
All material is more looks at the individual,
right?
And this is Mark's big,
uh,
our obsession.
The problem with modernity is the isolated Bush.
Why individual and we have to overcome these isolated individual and we have to
engage each other in human interaction.
He is a communitarian,
right?
He is a communist,
He does not want to have isolated individuals,
right?
They,
he wants a human interaction.
Uh,
well I,
I skipped this one.
Religious is also a still shot.
Productor um,
uh,
social life is practical.
This is again,
quite obvious and I can probably skip this one.
And here again,
you know,
the isolated individual,
that's the problem that you,
you do not see that really what we can achieve is all of us interacting with
each other and building on each other.
Um,
a single individual or you're not change anything.
Uh,
well,
and therefore we stand for socialized humanity.
The standpoint of old materialism is civil society and the isolated Bush.
Why individual in civil society and the afternoon get about a human society,
right there we are brothers and sisters,
right?
Then we have solidarity,
right where we act in concert and in solidarity and now comes a,
um,
uh,
the most controversial thesis.
Uh,
uh,
but I,
um,
hage and what I love,
uh,
love because again,
I think it is Var wonderfully done here because it's desperately wrong,
right?
Philosophers have only interpreted the world in various ways.
The point is to change it in some ways,
right?
This is follows from the earlier ideas.
Uh,
namely Baxis a cruise is a practical question.
A philosophy only makes sense if it changes your life.
If you just read the philosophy text or the theoretical text,
uh,
four foundations of modern social thought to make sure that we uveal fall
asleep,
then the text is something wrong than I did something wrong,
right?
Uh,
if you,
if the texts are right and if my lectures are right,
if you start reading the thesis on Feuerbach,
you cannot fall asleep,
right?
You may have to take a sleeping pill to quiet down and to sleep because the idea
of disturbed you because you'll feel now you have to change the world rather
than to accept it.
I don't know.
Thank you.